oh du bist janitschek report
hallo ich meine lieben freund und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen motto
juni wurde unter meine letzte motto
jugend zwar der disco modifikation die
könnt ihr auch wenn ihr unten in der
beschreibung auf minecraft mods playlist
klickt dann könnt ihr die da auch noch
mal angucken wollte dies sehr gut bei
euch angekommen und meinte hey mach doch
mal die kripo spezies motto ist
eigentlich ganz geil weil diese mod fügt
vier neue krebsarten bei euch ein spiel
hinzu also wenn ihr ihnen die ganz
normal diesem ort installierte läuft
nachts um dann kann es sein dass sie
einfach mal so auftreten also das ist
nicht so dass ihr linus born lassen kann
sondern getreten hat wirklich auf und
zwar haben wir da den hockey fight
creeper den angel creeper den ich sehr
gut finde den mystery trieb er dessen
item ich sehr cool finde und den netter
star clipper der halter des halters
taliban an
dann habe ich noch die ganz normalen
körper haben wir noch ein diamant
schwert gegeben und ein feuerzeug weil
wir in dem ein kraftwerks gelernt haben
kann man creeper mit einem feuerzeug
dazu bringen dass sie explodieren und
ich hab's links daneben eine kleine
notiz offen über die kripo und die items
die hinzugefügt werden da es gar die
sonne oft kann und ich würde sagen wir
gehen direkt das erste durch jetzt fast
dass der nette star clipper da steht
nämlich in dem forum des kriegers heft
triple of enorme explosion radio ffn
radio also die kann ich direkt töten
die haben einen dreimal so großen
explosions radios wie ein normaler
creeper die können das komplette haus
quasi kaputt sprengen also wenn sie im
haus sind können sie alles kaputt machen
und sie haben eine 0 1 prozentige chance
dass sie einen nenner stern droppen also
bei jedem tausendsten mal droppen sie
never stern das heißt wenn wir jetzt
einen kriegen jetzt echt unglaublich ich
mag vielleicht erst mal wer vielleicht
sinn verwehrt
wäre es unglaublich dass wir jetzt ein
kriegen würde wenn ich dir gleich töten
wir sehen erst mal so sieht der
aussetzer von lieferstellen der ist vom
gesicht auch ein bisschen anders
ich mache mich jetzt mal in den game
world 0
dann seht ihr schon der geht direkt auf
uns los ich versuchte ihn jetzt mal zu
töten so eine order oben sehen wir schon
angelripper die wollte ich ja später
zeigen der fliegt da schon rumba man das
coolste wird jetzt schon gezeigt der
angel küper sogar der kann nämlich
fliegen und ihr wollt ihr eigentlich am
ende zeigen ja okay der camcorder fallen
lassen
bei ihr müsst halt 1000 von denen spawn
und dann ist die chance hat dann solltet
ihr eigentlich einen nada stern kriegen
das war der rapper star clipper wir
kommt ich kann ja auch noch mal zeige
ich zeig euch jetzt ich töte den erst
mal zeigt euch dann was die gruppen wie
viele schläge die brauchen und danach
zeige ich euch mal was die von
explosions radios haben
den kann ich nicht anzünden ich kann
niemand die triberger anzünden oder muss
es leider doch so machen leider gottes
da muss ich das tut mir leid ich habe
eine volle diamant rüstungen und
trotzdem halben schaden halbe herzen
abgezogen bekommen und ich bin sogar
noch weg gegangen
ihr seht die explosion also der kann ein
wirklich wollen hätten wenn nicht gar
keine rüstung angehört oder nur eine
halbe rüsten sie in wien weil sie nicht
eine leder rüstung oder irgendwie so
oder eine gold russen aber ich glaube
ich tot gewesen
das ist der explosions rates ich zeige
es euch mal eben bei einem normalen
creeper wenn ich ihren normalen pieper
hat da sehen wir das loch eines normalen
treibhaus und da von diesem nähe von dem
werder star clipper also das ist richtig
richtig krass was der für eine power hat
und das
juckt ihn nicht einfach um ja egal so
gut dann haben wir hier nämlich den
mystery creek bei den mache ich mal als
nächstes in spa steht hier bei den
mystery park dies creepers tut appell
die radios auf explosion auf enorme
creeper der double die health auf enorme
keeper drobny ist resound bildet das
also das ist dieser mysteries ton den
man bekommt zeige ich euch gleich was
der macht sie machen den doppelten
explosions radios oder haben den
doppelten explosions radius wie dieser
kleine bub lag hier von dem normalen
prima er habe cooks weg gesagt die haben
die doppelte gesundheit doppelte was
können ist ja eigentlich gesundheit aber
doppelte lebensdauer sage ich mal von
einem normalen creeper und die droppen
einen mystery stone was der markt zeige
ich euch gleich mal und zwar ruckelt es
ein ganz klein bisschen weil ich hier
halt kein ob die fahnderin ab da ist
dieser krieg so ich versuchte die frau
zu töten 1233 terry 45
ich glaube sechs schläge braucht er oder
77 bei uns so hier sehen wir dann erst
mal die erfahrung der drops und zwar das
genau die gleiche wieder normale grippe
und jetzt haben wir diesen mystery stone
was der macht zeige ich euch gleich und
zwar tue ich den jetzt erstmal wieder
weg weil er jetzt ein wenig ungünstig
für die nächste situation die ich euch
zeigen möchte und zwar war das halt der
normale dieser 8er normale ich werde mir
übrigens auch die ganze zeit im game
roddick vogel
ich wollte ich auch zeigen was geschieht
wenn er explodiert diesem mystery creek
so sieht das ganze aus wenn explodiert
game mode 0
doppelter dingsbums wie normaler bub
fleck da vorne also wir sehen schon der
ist doppelt so groß und nicht drei mal
so groß also man sieht schon sehr
deutlich dass der hier viel viel größer
ist noch als der hier also das ist der
kleinste wenn ich mal nach oben fliegen
sieht man das glaube ich ganz gut
obst moment so man sieht dass das jetzt
dieser normale publikum normalen trikot
dann kommt hier der mystery krimi
mystery tiefer rein und kommt hier die
sander star clipper aber es gibt
natürlich noch mehr und zwar den angel
kritisierte schon da hinten denen können
wir einfach spawnen der flügel und
fliegt weg der kleine peugeot sogar wenn
man den schlägt seht ihr der greift
nicht mehr zurück an
auch wenn ich im gaylord gehe also wenn
ich aus dem haus gehe dann falle ich
hier herunter moment ich versuche mal
game mode 0
ihr seht explodiert nicht mehr fit halt
einfach nur weg im forum steht über den
angelripper dies creepers avenue model
and friendly denn john drop anything but
erfahrung denn und blow up and fly on in
the sky is also wenn man ihn tötet dann
juckt es sie nicht explodiert nicht der
greift nicht an der läuft nämlich
hinterher
das einzige was der job des erfahrung
und ist quasi wie ein vogel der macht
uns nix der prob knicks der sie dann von
einem schönen fliegt rum und tut mir
nicht weh so da kommen wir zum letzten
und zwar ist das der party feiert
creeper im forum steht portier economic
review des king of pop rock shop wir
wissen dass der keeper auf dem modell
eines schweines aufgebaut ist
deswegen das hab ich auch mal im mai
kräftig gesagt ich zeige euch den mal
ganz kurz wenn ich den hier warum ich
muss ich um gold in der eu fakt ist
vielleicht ein bisschen an ihm dran ich
los sie mal hier runter dass ich ihn
angreifen kann
richter noch ein schlag
also einfach ein creeper der so aussieht
wie ein schwein und er lässt auch port
fallen also okay der jetzt gar nichts
gedroppt es gibt natürlich auch immer
den fall dass sie wirklich gar nix prop
bet ist halt von der drop rate wirklich
wieder normaler krieg ich immer noch
eine neben hockeyfeld creeper ich töte
dich jetzt mal ganz kurz ihr alter [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
ich bin so ein hält aber egal ihr seht
schon er macht den gleichen schaden die
normaler körper ich will euch jetzt aber
zeigen dass dieser verdammte [ __ ]
auch gut habe ich nicht gesagt dass
dieser verdammte [ __ ] auch dort
fallen lässt das möchte ich ihnen ganz
gut zeigen
so habe ich dann erstmal ein bisschen
beruhigt da hinten wieder so ein angel
trug warum so 12.30 er hat zwei park
fallen lassen ist eigentlich ein school
es halt so wie seinen schweinen nur halt
gefährlich also die nächste variante des
schweins und jetzt sehen nämlich schon
was wir dort unten liegen haben uns war
es dass dieser mit respawn den und der
mystery creeper zu geworfen hat und
jetzt kann ich euch mal ganz kurz zeigen
wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise ein
ich muss ihm ein mystery creeper nehmen
ich nehme einfach diesen letter star
clipper bei der sehr sehr hart ist jetzt
gehe ich mal ganz kurz in den game mode
0cm eine rüstung aus spawn netter star
cooper
bin ich jetzt in die luft geflogen
moment mal ganz kurz moment das müssen
wir mal ganz kurz wiederholen ich hier
mal ganz kurz in game 0 1 wenn wir jetzt
hier einen mystery trieben und ich habe
dass sie beispielsweise daran gegen
gamer und 0 sporne ihn halte das ding
genannt versteht einem hesse canada
erscheint wenn ihr inventar revenge of
the exploding also eigentlich soll
dieser mysteries ton wenn man in der
hand hält oder wenn man den irgendwie
keine ahnung hat oder irgendwie so soll
der einfall explosionen waren oder warte
oder das liegt daran moment ich muss mal
ganz kurz das austesten
ich muss erst mal ganz kurz machen ich
glaube ich habe eine idee woran es
liegen könnte
ich habe mir mal eben eine ach so ein
bisschen ausrüstung und ich mir einfach
eben so jetzt mal ganz kurz in den
gamern immer ganz kurz da vorne
ich glaube nämlich ich weiß woran es
liegen könnte ich denke nämlich dass man
das nehmen muss was einem wirklich der
keeper ich habe gerade 1 gegeben 1
genommen einfach was auf dem boden lag
man sonst ist es einfach ein bug in dem
update was ich mir unter geladen von der
mod
jetzt so jetzt habe ich dieses teil
und wenn ich jetzt noch mal in den game
mode 1 gehe und jetzt nämlich
beispielsweise mal einfach ein krieger
damit ich nicht wieder direkt sterbe
setzt den dahin
okay wer kommt mir ein bisschen a game
mode 0 gehe ich zu dem hin
keine ahnung also irgendwie funktioniert
kann nicht mit dem mystery genre mystery
stone müsst ihr euch eigentlich vor der
explosion beschützen da werde ich auf
jeden fall mal den typen im forum an
schreiben warum hast du nicht
funktioniert weil die videos und in den
trailern wo ich das gesehen habe steht
das auch im forum steht hesse karl hat
nahm ancelotti inventories preview from
exploding es ist immer ein inventar ich
halt sogar in der hand ich hab sogar vor
dem krieg bekommen die nicht voll
getötet habe und esprit wenn ich vom
export ab also ich habe gerade auch eine
herz abgezogen bekommen ich weiß nicht
es hat sonst vor allen anderen job bei
mir plötzlich vielleicht habt ihr ladet
euch den motor einfach mal selbst runter
im forum
und dann würde ich sagen was das von der
mod review von dieser modifikation ich
bin auf jeden fall richtig cool gerade
den angie creeper und diese mysteries
ton finde ich eigentlich ist das geilste
was hinzugefügt wird weil es gehen wenn
man beispielsweise weihnachten pieper
töteten mystery creeper bekommt man halt
diesem mystery stone und kann damit dann
quasi wenn man in höhlen gehen will ein
bisschen was abbauen blabla und dann
wenn prima ankommt dann juckt mich nicht
weil ich habe dieses ding dann im
inventar oder als zehn vielleicht davon
wenn ich mehrere was geht wenn ich
mehrere mystery trieb er getötet habe
und keine ahnung also das ist auf jeden
fall richtig geilen vw nicht
funktioniert im forum steht ja auch das
eigentlich funktioniere sollte also
wahrscheinlich geht es bei mir einfach
nicht weil ich etwas falsch gemacht habe
oder so vielleicht jetzt aber euch links
in der beschreibung lässt euch gefallen
hat
trotz dieses komische fehlers mit dem
mystery stone zeigt mit einem mag ich
und schreibt eventuell weiteren die
kommentare empfiehlt dieses video weiter
keine ahnung jetzt wieder seht bin ich
gerade im urlaub und ich hab irgendwann
komischen sound gehört ich weiß aber
dass ingame bau der in warschau